I'm the Google are you we are on the
North Loop so technically you're not the
King though so we're a lion reading you
know us is food beast oh my god the
steak just melts GQ sent us across the
country to find the best cocktails food
and bars around
you're watching where's the bar we're on
a journey to find the best bars in
America so we stopped by the unassuming
Minneapolis on the North Loop and we're
checking out spoon and stable which is
supposedly one of the best bars in
America so we're gonna go in and see
what's good gentlemen see you welcome
guys spoon and stable we're taking
classic cocktails trying to figure out
what it is about each of them that makes
them that drink and then we're doing our
own special version of it everywhere you
go you're gonna get a different cocktail
no matter what so even when someone says
like this isn't a real old fashioned
well who made you a real old fashioned
like ever well I had the first one yeah
exact perfect and I'm a 7,000 years old
exactly so I mean like honestly like
we're just gonna take it very seriously
and make you a good dream the idea is
comfort food stuff that your grandma
makes but just our version of it it's
like stuff your grandma makes but better
and faster yeah kind of this used to be
a stable a lot of this stables were
built right on to the building's where
they were bringing up cargo and goods
these arches right here yeah are where
the actual horse stalls were where we
have our wine stable was the stable
doors this is the North Loop it's named
after a trolley car that used to go from
right into neighborhoods but also then
into the financial district of downtown
luckily some of the old buildings are
still here last time we came I was like
oh [ __ ] I really want to go see the
Mississippi River like I've never seen
it in my life it's crazy to me that
there's the Mississippi River that
basically kind of helped build America
yeah is right there it's a connector but
it's also how ideas and goods travel the
trade from the north shipping things
around through the Great Lakes that's
basically how Minneapolis was built
so dense with culture out here we have
an amazing music scene we have an
amazing art scene we have one of the
best dance communities in the country
yeah and there's these things that
people are just very passionate about
and just kind of care yeah
because honestly what why else would you
come here if you come here and really
have like a unique experience that you
can't have anywhere else that's really
cool and it's cool for us to be able to
go places like that where you're you
know kind of like oh like where you
going oh Minnesota like why it's a tiny
City you're obviously not in New York so
there's things that you know we can't
get food late at night right
that's ridiculous there's a bike
delivery called tacocat called what taco
cab they'll bring you tacos yo late at
night and they'll bike them already
Cory give me handle the order some tacos
so you got a pretty deep spread for us
here basically what we have for you
today is we're going to work on a punch
this is gonna be a holiday theme a lot
of flavors from Minnesota it's gonna be
called a warming house punch a warming
house is if you're ice skating you're
playing hockey you can come in and
that's where you change into normal
clothes but it becomes like a communal
is you family is sort of environment and
before cocktail was a thing punishments
are things we shall punch has a history
that's nuts it's definitely a thing and
there's a lot of places in this town and
in other towns where they actually have
a punch on the menu just as like a
friendly hello once you come in they'll
just pour you some punch
oh that's sweet first things first we're
gonna be adding Bombay Sapphire what it
does and white bartenders like it so
much it's because it basically ties
things together you do one bottle of gin
16 ounces of the cranberry cordial we're
gonna be adding a dried orange Curacao
it's about 16 ounces of water and for
hydration
we've got lime we're gonna be heading
bitters few dashes in here I'm just
gonna be topping it off with bubbles
you know it's holiday celebration time
it's the warming house punch to family
to friends Cheers togetherness with
alcohol Cheers
oh man it's awesome this is me the
opposite of glass I have to make it a
point on this show to always finish all
of the booze that's given to me because
I hate when you see those shows or
people like taste drinks and they're
like oh I think that was so delicious
let's go do something now to the north
kings of the north what sorry there
can't be multiple kings I don't know
what I was thinking
there's one my stomach is ready for some
northern hospitality if you know what
I'm saying all right hello chef how are
you good how are you pleasure that thing
is beautiful I can talk about it get me
maybe touch it this is a beef ribeye
okay it's 100 percent limousine beef is
what they call it witnessing the
limousine beef it's the type of cattle
we get in the ribeye we age it
downstairs and then once the mold starts
to form on the beef then we take what
you see here which is beef fat and we
just rub the beef fat all over the beef
like that we dry-aged this downstairs
for about 60 days 60 days yeah I mean it
is literally one of the most tender
pieces of beef I've ever eaten this is
very much who we are it's what we
believe in Peterson beef is a great
family-owned company that's in Wisconsin
it's a great synergy between us yeah and
that's very much owned in sable that's
cool that you reach back out yeah for
sure
so let's cook it we season it up a
little bit and this is gonna take about
45 minutes to cook this is another part
of the dish that we do this is the tato
version so we take sheets of potato and
you just roll the potato like that and
it cuts into a very very long strip we
take caramelized onions x and pecorino
cheese and we just roll it up it's a
very classic potato dish in France it's
called a palm Lyon a will poach that in
duck fat oh well because I mean why not
at that point
then we deep-fry it all right there
right yeah you will I should actually
maybe not let you taste it just to be
cruel no yeah
45 minutes later just like a cooking
show
yeah oh my god magic see that comes out
of the oven let's start with the
potatoes so we confit namond duck fat
and then he deep-fried it broccoli rabe
so we take the chain off here I mean
honestly that's gonna change your life
I feel like I need to hug you up for
them this is just the natural beach shoe
we have chives we have beef fat inside
of it as well and then we add a little
fleur de sel tray here pinky out so you
get that get your potatoes you get your
salt and that that's how we eat for us
this the simplicity of the food is
shining through you hear about steak
melting in your mouth but that one like
I'm barely chewing and it was falling
apart that literally melts it
look how spending the layers are that's
a breakfast every day right this is the
chop the actual rib portion of the beef
yeah give me a little king of the north
has got away from me king of the new
ownership game-changer right now yeah
there you go come to Minneapolis to eat
its food and stable it's absolutely
worth it and then go bang around the
whole neighborhood and get weird I love
it you know what I'm Sam
thank you really they're all dirty no
that's good I'd rather have you have
beef fat on your hands so this is where
it starts oh this is where it ends the
Mississippi River this is where we throw
Nathaniel off the bridge for thinking in
you just saw for yourselves stable and
spoon is
oh so you saw for yourself spoon and
stable has it going on when it comes to
cocktails the stake is through the roof
don't sleep once booting stable that's
what you got to go yeah thank you very
much guys come visit us in the north